ja willkommen zur
online-vorlesung und Probleme der
praktischen Philosophie eine digitale
ersatzsitzung am 6 juni 2023 heute
möchte ich zu Beginn des ganzen
begriffsnetz was wir uns bisher
erarbeitet haben und was wir uns heute
erarbeiten werden noch vorstellen als
wir beginnen wir immer mit der Person
oder der menschlichen Tier je nachdem
was als Subjekt der Handlung aufgefasst
wird das kann natürlich individuell und
im Falle der Person Kollektiv sein es
ist etwas problematisch von einem
kollektiven Tier auszugehen kollektive
Person hingegen sind sehr wohl denkbar
ja den Handlungsbegriff Unterschieden
darauf möchte ich jetzt gar nicht
weitergehen wir sind auf den Grund
eingegangen der letzten Vorlesung auf
Gründe und auch auf die Vernunft haben
zwischen instrumenteller oder
orthetischer Vernunft und kategorische
moralische von uns unterschieden und
haben David
zu kontrastierend auch diskutiert ich
gehe dabei heute noch mal genauer ein
bisschen darauf ein wir haben den
Begriff der Willensschwäche schon
geklärt Selbsttäuschung wird noch ein
Grund im Thema sein ob das wir näher
eingehen werden auch als formte
Irrationalität der praktischen Unfällen
heute soll es um diese linke Seite gehen
um Freiheit da kann man positiv und
negative Freiheit voneinander
unterscheiden man kann zwischen
Handlungsfreiheit und Willensfreiheit
auf seine positiven Freiheit
unterscheiden und die willensfrei ist
das interessantere Phänomen von beidem
und da können wir dann noch den Begriff
der Autonomie genauer erklären und auch
der termination Notwendigkeit
Indifferenz als Formen oder als
Bezugspunkte der Willensfreiheit uns
überlegen und in der Kombination dieser
Formen ergeben sich dann verschiedene
Positionen wie kompatibilismus und
inkompatibilismus bezüglich der
lebensfreiheit hatte Determinismus und
lieber tariieren es muss eins zwei
Unterarten von ihnen kompatibilismus was
ist damit auf sich hat werde ich jetzt
gleich noch genauer erklären
wir kommen dann auch noch zum Schluss
auf Emotionen zu sprechen anhand der
Liebe wollen wir uns fragen wie
Emotionen mit Handlung zusammenhängen
und es wird sich zeigen dass Liebe und
der Grundbegriff in einem gewissen
Verhältnis zueinander stehen je nachdem
wie man jetzt Liebe versteht heutiges
Programm also was ist Handlungsfreiheit
was ist Willensfreiheit und Handlungen
und Emotionen
zunächst einmal rückblick zum Thema
praktische Vernunft es gibt verschiedene
rationale Operationen wo wir unsere
Zukunft einsetzen können betätigen
können vergleichen abwägen zum Beispiel
von Gründen allgemeinen auf
Widersprüchlichkeit in prüfen
analysieren in kleinere Teile Fragen
Probleme zerlegen Schlüsse ziehen und
Urteilen urteilen wird häufig als eines
der wichtigsten
Operation von Vernunft praktische
Vernunft Verstand verstanden
induktive Schlüsse die verallgemeinern
da haben wir dann also wieder diese
Operation mit einbezogen die
Allgemeinheit von einer endlichen
beobachteten Anzahl auf eine höhere
nicht beobachtete Anzahl also
erweiterungslos sozusagen eine tierische
erweiterungsschluss oder deduktiver
Schluss wenn wir von sicheren Prämissen
aus etwas ableiten logisch Gehalts
bewahrend nicht empirisch ja und das
richtige Mittel zu einem Zweck finden
und wählen das ist dann die
instrumentelle
jetzt kann man sich fragen gibt es dann
auch so dass wir eine moralische
Vernunft die nicht nur sagt was für ein
Mittel wir zu einem bestimmten
vorgegebenen Zweck wählen müssen sein
welchen Zweck wir verfolgen zahlen und
zwar absolut unbedingt ein moralischer
Zweck zum Beispiel und das ist eine ganz
strittige Frage in der Philosophie ob es
auch moralische Vernunft gibt
Immanuel Kant hat den Begriff des
kategorischen hypothetischen Imperativs
geprägt in seiner Grundlegung zu mit der
Sitten da mache ich dann auch oben
rechts ein Link rein zu einer Sendung zu
diesem Seminar zu diesem Berg
er sagt alle imperative Gebieten
entweder hypothetisch oder kategorisch
und der kategorische Imperativ würde der
sein welcher eine Handlung als für sich
selbst ohne Beziehung auf einen anderen
Zweck als objektiv notwendig vorstellt
also Zweck an sich nicht nur Mittel zum
Zweck das sind die hypothetischen
imperative also die Form des
hypothetischen Imperativs lautet wenn du
x erreichen möchtest dann musst du dafür
jetzt tun y ist Mittel zum zwecks der
kategorische Imperativ lautet x
unbedingt zum Beispiel ist eine Form des
kategorischen Parties eine konkrete Form
du sollst ihn als Lügen die kategorische
Imperativ sagt uns aber nicht ganz genau
konkret in einer Situation behandeln
sollen sondern er ist recht allgemein
gehalten wir müssen dann immer noch mit
unserer Urteilskraft unsere Erfahrung
den kategorischen partitiv auf die
jeweilige Situation beziehen
jetzt möchte ich noch auf der Beziehung
zu sprechen kommen wir nicht viele
historische Bezugspunkte im amerikantes
einer der hauptbezugspunkt und seinen
Gegenspieler obwohl die sich gar nicht
wirklich gestritten haben weil der
Beziehung vorkannt gelebt hatte sein
Gegenspieler ist eben die Beziehung und
man kann und der Beziehung sagt wir
drücken uns nicht genau und
philosophisch aus wenn wir von einem
Kampf zwischen Affekt und Vernunft reden
die Vernunft sagt dir und jetzt kommts
ist nur der Sklave der Effekt und soll
es auch sein sie darf niemals eine
andere Funktion beanspruchen als die
denselben nämlich den Affekten zu dienen
und zu gehorchen starke these also es
gibt nur instrumentelle Vernunft ist das
Motto von Jung und ich will uns selbst
die kann selbst gar keine Motive und
Ziele vorgeben die dann von den Affekten
unterstützt werden
ein weiteres Zitat was gegen den
Auffassung einer moralischen Vernunft
spricht es läuft zeitum der Vernunft
nicht zu wieder wenn ich lieber die
Zerstörung der ganzen Welt will als an
Ritz an meinem Finger es widerspricht
nicht davon und wenn ich meinen
vollständigen Ruin auf mich nehme um das
kleinste Unbehagen eines Indianers oder
einer mir gänzlich unbekannten Personen
zu verhindern ist verstößt ebenso wenig
gegen die vernünftig das erkannte Maße
für mich weniger gute den besseren
vorziehen und zu dem ersten größeren
eigenen empfinde als du das letzte Teil
auch wieder eine starke these dann
würden die meisten sagen es widerspricht
eben doch der Vernunft wenn wir unseren
vollständigen grün aufnehmen
um das kleinste Unterlagen einer uns
fremden Person zu verhindern noch
extremer wenn wir lieber die Zerstörung
der ganzen Welt wollen als andere
das scheint gegen die Vernunft zu sein
Team sagt ist es aber nicht warum weil
Vernunft und Affekt auf gar nicht
derselben Ebene operieren die sind
gewissermaßen windschief die haben gar
kein Bezugspunkt weil sie auf ganz
andere Bereiche gerichtet sind Immanuel
Kant hat es dann natürlich anders
gesehen er hat gesagt es gibt eine
moralische Vernunft die sogar in einem
Kampf mit den Effekten eintreten kann
die uns Beleidigungen abweisen kann
sagte
ja so viel zu jung und jetzt aber zur
heutigen Sitzung heute geht es um das
große Thema Freiheit das ist vielleicht
eine der wichtigsten Begriffe für die
praktische Philosophie nach dem Begriff
der Handlung gibt dir wichtige
Unterscheidungen positive freiheit ist
die Freiheit zu etwas negative freiheit
ist die Freiheit von etwas und kann man
jetzt noch Handlungsfreiheit
unterscheiden das bedeutet tun können
was man will die meisten im Alltag
würden denken das ist die volle Freiheit
wenn wir diese Freiheit haben dann
braucht man nicht mehr aber in der
Philosophie wird noch eine andere Form
davon unterschieden nämlich die
Willensfreiheit und die kann man auf die
Formel bringen wollen können was man
will kann man sich fragen wenn ich etwas
will dann muss ich doch nicht mehr
normal wollen dann will ich doch dann
kommst doch nur noch drauf an ob ich das
auch tun kann also viele würden sagen
handlungsfrei ist völlig ausreichend
willenseitig ist überhaupt nicht nötig
das ist super eruggatorisch
gewissermaßen vieler über Erfüllung der
freiheitsbedingungen oder manche würden
sogar auch sagen das ist sinnlos den
Willen zu wollen dass es ein Widerspruch
in sich der Wille will doch wieso soll
man den Willen dann noch wollen wir
müssen uns überlegen welche Gründe dafür
sprechen auch noch sowas wie
Willensfreiheit anzunehmen
es gibt jetzt verschiedene Argumente für
die Handlungsfreiheit ich habe schon ein
paar genannt nicht der Wille ist frei
ist könnte man sagen sondern der
handelnde Mensch es gibt keine
Willensfreiheit das hat zum Beispiel in
der philosophischen Tradition John Lock
gesagt auch ein empiristischer Philosoph
ähnlich wie David jung der Grund warum
wir geneigt sind zu sagen der Wille sein
frei besteht darin dass wir diesen als
ein handelndes Wesen betrachten also
personifizieren dies führt jedoch zu
einer Gedanken Verwirrung sagt eben
dieser John locker der Wille ist nur
eine Kraft oder Fähigkeit das heißt eine
Eigenschaft für Menschen
Eigenschaften können sie sich selbst
nicht existieren sondern sie brauchen
immer etwas dem sie anhaften der Wille
und die Freiheit haften als
Eigenschaften den Menschen an deswegen
kann der Wille nicht weiß sein weil er
nämlich eine Eigenschaft ist meine
Eigenschaft kann keine anderen
Eigenschaften haben sagt schon laut die
Quelle unserer Freiheit liegt in unsere
Fähigkeit unsere Wünsche und begehrungen
und aus einer kritischen Distanz zu
reflektieren das ist das allermeiste was
schon Lok zu gibt für unsere Freiheit
genügt das Thema tun zu können was wir
wollen
und es ist die besteht nicht darin
wollen zu können was man will das ist
also nicht nötig oder sogar sinnlos so
viel die Vertreter der Handlungsfreiheit
es steht dagegen die Argumentation für
die Willensfreiheit
und die lautet folgendermaßen
Willensfreiheit besteht im Gegensatz zu
Handlungsfreiheit darin unseren Willen
selbst zu bestimmen es genügt nicht zu
tun was man will sondern unser Wille
muss kritisch geprüft und reflektiert
werden wir müssen selbst die Ursachen
unseres wollen sein und nicht nur unsere
Handlungen es könnte nämlich sonst sein
dass unser Wille manipuliert wurde und
der gar nicht unser eigener Wille ist
der würde uns gewissermaßen von außen
einfach eingegeben die Autonomie besteht
dann darin das ist eine
Weiterentwicklung eine konsequentere
Gedanke der Lebensweise wir müssen uns
selbst die Gesetze unseres Handelns und
vor allem unseres geben natürlich ist
hier im Mangel kann besonders gemeint
wenn es um die Autonomie geht es kann
man sich allerdings fragen inwiefern
sind wir frei uns die Gesetze des
Wollens und Handels zu geben wie können
wir das eigentlich tun
wir sehen die Willen zweiten ist
philosophisch viel problematischerweise
auch viel anspruchsvoller ist als die
Handlungsfreiheit
maximal erkannt ein bisschen hier
eingehen und auf seinem Begriff der
Autonomie er sagt folgendes in seiner
Grundlegung zu mir darf ich der singen
Autonomie des Willens ist die
Beschaffenheit des Willens dadurch
derselbe ihm selbst unabhängig von einer
Beschaffenheit der Gegenstände des
Wollens ein Gesetz ist das Prinzip der
Autonomie ist also nicht anders zu
wählen als so dass die Maximen seiner
Wahl in demselben wollen zugleich als
allgemeines Gesetz mit Begriffen sein
und er sagt noch was das Gesetz der
Autonomie ist nicht irgendein Gesetz
sagt er sondern es ist unser eigenes
Gesetz wenn es nämlich ein anderes
Gesetz wäre ein fremdes Gesetz dann wäre
es nicht unser Gesetz und ein
heteronomes
entfremdgesetzes Gesetz und Heteronomie
und Autonomie muss man nach ganz streng
voneinander unterscheiden kann man sich
aber fragen was sind wir im Grunde
menschliche Tiere die nach Glück streben
dann wäre unsere Gesetz das unser
Handeln leidet das Glücks empfinden die
glücksmaximierung oder Personen die nach
Moral Streben dann wäre es das
Sittengesetz nachdem wir streben müssen
ja es gibt es verschiedene Probleme der
Autonomie wie können wir uns als
Freiheit eingesetzt geben wenn wir doch
immer schon unter einem Gesetz stehen
müssen und frei zu sein das ein Problem
wenn das autonome Gesetz das
Sittengesetz ist wir können uns dann
automatisch gegen das sieben Gesetz und
für das unmoralische Entscheidung muss
ja auch frei sein das Böse was wir tun
weil sonst könnte es uns nicht
zugerechnet werden sind wir im Innersten
wirklich moralischen Wesen so dass unser
eigenes Gesetz unseres wollen und
Handelns im Grunde immer ein moralisches
ist
diese Frage muss man natürlich ankannt
stellen
jetzt komme ich zu zwei ganz wichtigen
Positionen die die Willen Freiheit
betreffen nämlich den kompatibilismus
und den inkompatibilismus
bedeutet willensfrei ist mit der
termination vereinbar oder kompatibel
deswegen heißt der kompatibilismus
Beispiele gründete terminieren und sie
handeln aber Gründe sind nicht
naturkosadeursachen also unsere Wille
ist bestimmt determiniert durch Gründe
aber weil es Gründe sind die nicht in
Natur aus der Ursachen tätig sind sind
wir darin trotzdem frei
das kann man sich natürlich fragen wie
man die Realität von Gründen erklären
kann der inkompatibilismus auf der
anderen Seite sagt Willensfreiheit ist
mit determination nicht vereinbaren
und dann kann man zwei verschiedene
Formen unterscheiden des
inkompatibilismus einmal der harte
Determinismus der Determinismus ist wahr
also alles was auf der Welt geschieht
ist der terminiert und deswegen sind wir
nicht Willensfreiheit das entsteht da
natürlich ein Problem daraus wir sind
nämlich da nicht für unsere Handlung
verantwortlich wenn sie ja völlig
vorherbestimmt sind durch das
Naturgesetz zum Beispiel der
libertarianismus auf der anderen Seite
ist auch ein inkompatibel ist aber er
sagt der Germanismus ist falsch und die
willens deswegen war
das Problem ist es gibt dann
eventuell nach Auffassung des netatmungs
naturgesetzliche Lücken also Phänomene
Ereignisse die eigentlich gar nicht der
terminiert sind ist Freiheit mit dem
Indeterminismus vereinbar sind wir
willensfrei wenn unsere Willen nicht
bestimmt ist das muss man sich auch
fragen
es gibt ja ein Konsequenz Argument von
einem bekannten amerikanischen
Philosophen Peter von invegen und er
sagt if the Germany's Miss true than our
acts are the consequences of the laws of
nature on the rains in the remote past
damit ist dann sind unsere jetzigen
Handlungen lose Konsequenzen vergangener
gültiger Gesetze wartet ist not up to us
what went on the forever is it UPS of
nature also wir können nicht entscheiden
was vor unsere Geburt der Fall war und
die Naturgesetze die auch schon vor
unserer Geburt Geltung besaßen die
kümmere auch nicht beeinflussen der
Vorsatz hat von ihm wegen der
quansequenz ist obwist inklusive Acts
deswegen sind auch die Konsequenzen
dieser vorhandenen vergangenen Zustände
und auch der Dinge die wir jetzt tun
nicht uns zuzuschreiben sie hängen nicht
von uns ab das ist das Konsequenz auch
und aus folgt natürlich dass die
Willensfreiheit problematisch ist
Immanuel Kant hatten ähnliches Argument
Menschen wie früher hat gesagt darum die
vergangene Zeit nicht mehr in meiner
Gewalt ist so muss jede Handlung dich
ausübe durch bestimmte Gründe die nicht
in meiner Gewalt sind notwendig sein das
heißt ich bin in dem Zeitpunkt gegangen
niemals frei
kann man sich fragen ist dann
Willensfreiheit ein Mysterium also
wenn wir unseren Verstand anstrengen
müssen wir eigentlich denken
alles ist determiniert also kann
rational gesehen der Wille gar nicht
frei sein trotzdem haben wir ganz starke
Intuition dass wir will ins frei sind
und verantwortlich für unsere Taten und
das ist ein Konflikt und Peter von Ihnen
beiden hat deswegen
davon gesprochen dass es ein Mysterium
ist übrigens weit gefree will ist in
company Terminal we are face with Mistry
for free will an die neue exit
it all the season
in der terminismus
also wir haben sie mit einem Mysterium
zu tun so sagt es jedenfalls wieder von
ihm weg
es gibt auch noch Vertreter des harten
Determinismus der hat einen Aufsatz
geschrieben mit dem provokativen Titel
keiner kann anders als er ist
und Wolf singer hat diese These aus der
Perspektive der Hirnforschung er ist
nämlich in Hirnforschung formuliert er
hat gesagt all unser Denken und Tun ist
mit dem Ablaufen neuronale Prozent zu
erklären
wir sollten aufhören von Freiheit zu
reden also hier wird ein neuronaler
Determinismus angenommen der unsere
Freiheit speziell unsere Willensfreiheit
bestreitet er sagt genetischen Faktoren
früh bewegt Prägung und soziale
lernfaktoren aktuelle Auslösung sie sind
auch Befehle Wünsche und Argumente
andere zählen wirken stets untrennbar
zusammen und legen das Ergebnis fest
gleich ob sich Entscheidungen mehr
unbewussten oder bewussten Motiven
verdanken sie bestimmen gemeinsam die
dynamischen Zustände entscheidende
nervenzen weiteres Argument von seiner
Seite genetische Dispositionen können
Verschaltungen hervorgebracht haben das
Speichern oder abrufen sozialer Regeln
erklären oder die sozial in der Regel
wird nicht rechtzeitig und tief genug
eingeprägt oder es wurden von der Norm
abweichende Regeln erlernen oder die
Fähigkeit zu rationalen Abwägungen nur
deswegen fehlgeleiteter Prägung
ungenügend ausdifferenziert diese Liste
ließe sich nahezu beliebig verlängern
jetzt kommt sein Motto keiner kann
anders als er ist und er ist eben er
oder sie ist eben neuronal determiniert
soziologisch aber eben auch im organisch
ja also
willenforschung Willensfreiheit die
stehen einem Spannungsverhältnis
zueinander noch ein Zitat diese Einsicht
könnte zu einer humanerin weniger
diskriminierenden Beurteilung von
Mitmenschen führen die das Pech hatten
mit einem Organ nämlich dem Gehirn
volljährig geworden zu sein dessen
funktionelle Architektur in kein
angepasstes Verhalten erlaubt Menschen
mit problematischen
Verhaltensdisposition als schlecht oder
böse abzurteilen bedeutet nichts anderes
als das Ergebnis einer schicksalshaften
Entwicklung des sonnenorgans das unser
Wesen aus noch zu beantworten beschreibt
das Fehlverhalten eine Toleranzgrenze
wohnen wir mit Sanktion
interessanterweise fallen diese
Maßnahmen umzutastische aus je mehr wir
davon ausgehen können dass dem der Link
finden die Variablen auf den die
Entscheidung passierte bewusst sein
müssen offenbar ahnen wir Verstöße dann
besonders
wir begründen dies indem ihr bewussten
Entscheidung ein besonderes Maß an
Freiheit zuschreiben und daraus
besondere Schuldfähigkeit
Verantwortlichkeit und sanktions
Notwendigkeit ableiten ja das ist also
seine These und die ist natürlich
strittig und problematisch weil nach
diese hirnorganischen these hätten wir
gar keine Freiheit wie muss man dann
umgehen mit Menschen die zum Beispiel
eine Bank überfallen muss man dann sagen
das war einfach deren Gehirn das hat
einfach nicht richtig funktioniert es
ist so einfach dann kann man natürlich
mit guten Gründen zweifeln dennoch ist
es ganz schwierig wenn es weit
philosophisch zu begründen und gegenüber
dem der terminismus zu profilieren zu
verteidigen jetzt kommen wir zum
nächsten Thema der heutigen digitalen
Vorlesung zu dem Thema Emotionen kann
sich jetzt fragen unterscheiden sich
Emotionen von Gefühlen können Emotionen
rational und Gründe unseres Handelns
sein also die verhalten sich emotionen
können Emotionen zu machen aktivieren
wir haben ja schon mal gesehen Gründe
können auch motivationale Gründe sein
können Emotionen auch Gründe sein was
sind moralische Gefühle das wollen wir
auch noch kurz anschneiden was ist eine
Emotion es gibt hier eine Geschichte der
Philosophie ganz viele Vertreter von
Emotionstheorien die eine besondere
Emotionen Zentrum Stellen der Beziehung
hat es mitleidungszentrum besteht
Immanuel kann die Achtung Schleiermacher
und Schäler die Scham zarte den Ekel
kirchiger und die Verzweiflung Martin
Heidinger die Angst als totlösen Platon
Neid und Eifersucht und Augustinus
Frankfurt auf den Leuten her eingehen
die liebe es sind ganz zentrale
Emotionen sage ich jetzt muss man sich
natürlich fragen wie können wir
Emotionen Effekte Gefühle und Stimmungen
voneinander trennscharf unterscheiden
hier ein Vorschlag Effekte vollziehen
sich sehr schnell und intensiv so dass
wir Behandlungen immer perfekt nicht
viel reflektieren und vorstellen
sind deswegen keine guten Gründe
Verhandlung
Beleidigung immer perfekt
Stimmungen halten an und legen sich wie
ein Schleier über uns Gefühle sind
äußerlich über wie Schmerz oder
Emotionen drücken dagegen unsere
Subjektivität aus und erlauben zugleich
eine Reflexion deswegen eignen sie sich
als Gründe und Motive für unser Handeln
Emotionen sind also ausgezeichnet
gegenüber Affekten Stimmen und losen
Gefühlen wie hängen jetzt Emotionen mit
unserem Handeln zusammen ich habe schon
gesagt Harry Fremdwort den wir schon
kennengelernt haben als es um die Frage
nach dem Begriff des Willens gegen
Stichwort second order-volutions der hat
sich auch dazu geäußert in einem Buch
mit dem titelity volition in love
und einem anderen Buch mit dem Titel the
reasons of Love in Deutsch Übersetzung
Gründe der Liebe kann Liebe ein Grund
sein von seinen ein guter Grund
vielleicht
er sagt loving someone aus something
Essen
ist
interessantes love is itself vor dem
Lover
witch is acts of loving konzentrieren
also liebe sind Gründe
von Quellen von Gründen das Gefühl der
Liebe dann kann ein Grund sein und die
besser gesagt die Emotion
er sagt auch noch was er sagt nämlich in
der Liebe
betrachten wir eine andere Person weil
wir nämlich uns um Sie kümmern wir
sorgen uns um sie nordmeerly Azam means
but
wir betrachten die andere Person zu be
valual in dem selfs und wir handeln vor
der und Sex also das hat natürlich was
mit dem kategorischen Imperativ analoge
wir sind in der Liebe nicht nur so
eingestellt gegenüber einer anderen
Person dass sie als Mittel zum Zwecke
brauchen instrumental hypothetisch sein
absolut kategorisch gibt es eine ganz
enge nette liebe zur Moral wir gehen
jetzt Emotionen und unser Handeln
zusammen nach Frankfurt ist Liebe ein
Quelle und unsere Gründe unsere Handelns
damit stehen Liebe und Vernunft
emotionalitäten Rationalität sich nicht
den geben Liebe besitzt mich schon sagte
eine Ähnlichkeit du kannst kategorischem
Imperativ das fordert eine andere Person
als selbstweg zu behandeln und diesen
Anspruch zugleich mit guten Gründen kann
das ist das Thema Emotion gewesen wir
gehen der nächsten physischen Vorlesung
dann noch genau mal drauf ein auch
anhand von unserem Beispiel Immanuel
ganz Begriff der Achtung und gehen dann
über zum Thema moralische Motivation was
bestimmt unseren Willen was motiviert
uns zu einer Handlung und auch da werden
Emotionen wie Liebe oder auch Achtung
eine große Rolle spielen vielen Dank für
die Aufmerksamkeit